[Music]
In this problem, during a hazardous
waste test burn, three designated
principal organic hazardous constituents
or PHC's
are incinerated at 1,000° C. The waste
feed stream was measured accurately, but
the outlet concentration gauge
malfunctioned.
Fortunately, the monitoring computer
still reports the destruction and
removal efficiencies or DRE.
Assuming the required DR is 99.99%,
determine the present outlet
concentration of the constituent in
kilogram/ hour that is currently not in
compliance.
So this question is very easy to solve
and is basically just here to get you
familiar with another section in the
reference manual. So we can see our
given table down here requires each of
our principal organic hazardous
constituents
and we have the inlet concentration
that's going into the test burn for each
one. We're missing the outlet
concentration because the gauge is
broken, but the monitoring computer is
still giving us the
actual
um destruction and removal efficiencies.
So, the question's asking us to pick the
one that's not in compliance to find the
outlet information for.
So if we have 99.99%
as our required DR, well the only one
down here that doesn't meet that is
tricloroethylene.
So
searching the reference manual for
either DR or destruction and removal
efficiency
will take us straight to chapter 2 on
air to a section called incineration on
page 80.
And
this equation is just written as
follows.
So
d r e
equ= w in minus w out
over w out
time 100%.
where DR is the destruction and removal
efficiency,
WIN is the mass feed rate of a
particular principal organic hazardous
constituent
and W out is the mass emission rate of
that same principal organic hazardous
constituent.
So, we're given all of the information
we need to solve this problem right
away. So, let's get to it.
We can see that
[Music]
our given DR for tricloroethylene
is going to be 9975%.
And that's going to be equal to our
inlet concentration of 300.
This is going to be kilograms per hour,
but I'm just going to leave that off.
minus our unknown W out which we want to
find
over the inlet again
times 100%.
So
to simplify this equation we can drop
the percentages from first each side of
the equation
and then divide by 100. So this will
give us 0.99975
equals
300 - W out
over 300
which if we rearrange the equations
or if we simplify a little bit more
we can multiply by 300 100 on each side
to get 29925
equals
300 minus
W out. And now if we rearrange we can
see that W
out equals
300 minus
or 0.075
which is our third answer over here.
And that's all it takes to solve this
problem. The whole point of this
particular question is just to get you
familiar with the idea of test burns,
principal organic hazardous
constituents, and where to find the
destruction and removal efficiency
equation in the reference manual. And
that's it.
[Music]